We know that there will be very difficult days ahead in Iraq.
There will probably be more violence.
But like any sovereign, independent nation,...
...Iraq must be free to chart its own course.
No one should seek to influence, exploit or disrupt this period of transition.
Now is the time for every neighbor and nation...
...to respect Iraq's sovereignty and territorial integrity.
A new Iraqi government will face important decisions about Iraq's future.
But as today's voting demonstrates,...
...the Iraqi people want disagreements to be debated...
...and decided through a political process that provides security and prosperity for all Iraqis.
And as they go forward,...
...the Iraqi people must know that the United States will fulfill its obligations.
We will continue with the responsible removal of United States forces from Iraq.
Indeed for the first time in years,...
...there are now fewer than 100,000 American troops serving in Iraq.
By the end of August, our combat mission will end.
As I said last year, when I announced our new strategy in Iraq,...
...we will continue to advise and assist Iraqi Security Forces,...
...carry out targeted counterterrorism operations with our Iraqi partners,...
...and protect our forces and civilians.
And by the end of next year, all U.S. troops will be out of Iraq.